it what's up guys mkbhd here back with
another high definition of a review of
the beats by dre studios and this is
more of a casual video review as I
haven't really had a lot of time to do a
couple of things lately including making
the highly edited professional videos
but those are coming back in the near
future
until then what I really want to show
you is my honest opinion of these
headphones and what you get for the
money when you pay for them so these are
currently provided by monster cable
these are the white studios and I'm
showing you the box right now because I
was really impressed with this packaging
very nicely put together well
constructed but enough with the
packaging I didn't actually do an
unboxing of these so I'll show you what
comes in the box with the studios inside
here are the headphones and the 3.5
millimeter cable this is another
three-and-a-half millimeter cable but
it'll also have the control talk and
right there that's the control talk
microphone volume up and volume down
what you're also going to get is a beach
by dre little user manual this is all
white since these are the white studios
I'm assuming you will get a black
version with the black studios but this
is pretty cool you'll also get an
airline adapter with this and of course
the nice red beats microfiber so one of
my favorite things about this company is
a red black color scheme anything anyway
we're gonna go ahead and take a look at
the studio's themselves
pardon my my injured shoulder so I can't
really do much with two hands here but
this is a really nice hard case you
can't really damage the headphones when
they're in here though they do appear
soft so something I'll show you guys
here we open up the pillow shell and
these are the Beats Studios themselves
which we'll take a look at in a second
we also have is this removable pouch
this patch has two sides to it you can
take the three-and-a-half millimeter
cable out which is the gold-tipped right
angle cable for the mp3 player and the
other end is for the beats themselves
this is the the pouch that goes beside
the case here so it's a nice little case
these really won't be leaving my house
so I really do enjoy having a hard case
a shell case to protect
when I do actually move into somewhere
so these are the headphones like you saw
they are not actually connected to the
cable that's because right here on the
left hand side you can connect your
three-and-a-half millimeter cable and
that will be so in case you damage the
cable you don't have to buy a whole new
pair of headphones so taking an actual
hardware tour before we talk about the
sound and the comfortability these are
the the foam cushions you can of course
check this out at the beats by dre comm
website but i'm gonna go over with it
anyway this is a little aluminum on the
left hand side of course this part here
is adjustable so it's a little bit less
fragile than this solo HD is I would say
much more sturdy that happens on both
sides and there of course labeled right
and left these are noise cancelling
headphones so you'll have the triple-a
batteries in here and there's also a
power button right there so you are
power switch you can flick it actually
I'll go ahead and turn it on for you
when you turn them on you get a little
amber light here and it'll be red when
they're on and it'll turn a different
color when the batteries are loved I say
battery because we can open up this on
the left hand side compartment and there
are two triple A batteries in here for
noise cancellation a downside is that
you can't actually use the headphones
without the batteries so you either have
noise cancellation or no sound at all
you can twist to right back on to get
them to work again using these
headphones I found that they were
extremely comfortable this has been by
far the most comfortable easy to use
pair of headphones I've ever used up at
the top here this is a very soft foam
you can probably go to Best Buy and
check these out but this all the way all
around this really really soft it's
comfortable it'll mesh fit to your head
as it's pretty flexible you can see here
and these aren't going to break if
you're using them in a studio they're
also a little adjustable here with the
ear cups on the left and the right hand
side and something else to talk about is
of course in any pair of headphones they
sound quality the sound quality is
really really top-notch on these
headphones so what I want to talk about
the first lows mids and highs I've
reviewed these solo HD is not too long
ago and you can check out a link I'll
have an annotation right above here to
the solo HD review video and the bass
was really hot in those this the bass
was really accentuated we
great for music listening but not really
too good for studio monitoring and
headphones like these you're going to
get very very balanced sound solos mids
and highs are all very very crisp and
very well accentuated with these
headphones which really makes them quite
good so using them in the studio you can
of course adjust them to fit your head
and really no matter how big or small
your head is they will work and I found
them very comfortable able to wear for a
couple of hours and the studios really
live up to their name and the price that
you actually pay for them go ahead and
turn it over here with the white studios
also something to mention is you'll get
this black and gray at the top and with
the solo HDS with fur black it was a
black and gray or actually a red and
gray lettering so that's would be the
case with the black studios so if you
want to check out more information about
the beats by dre studios you can check
that out this has been a more casual
review like I said of the headphones I
use these with the Zune HD so I'll be
using the this out the way here I'll be
using the simple red and black cable I
love red black of course those are my
favorite colors but this is the
three-and-a-half millimeter right angled
cable and the end that actually plugs
into the left hand side of the studio's
control talk does not work as of yet
with the Zune or the Zune HD so you
won't actually be able to click without
actually moving you'll actually have to
take it out your pocket and you know
adjust those things but I really like to
use the studio's and these will be my
permanent editing headphones for mkbhd
videos from now on so this man mkbhd
with the review of the beats by dre
studios thanks for watching this video
and I'll talk to you guys in the next
one if you'd like to view another review
of the beats by dre studio that's
recently come out you can check out
duncan 3-3 303's review here he's done a
video recently he also got the new beats
by dre studios from monster cable who
had an excellent PR team by the way
great product resource neat great um
personal relations team so if you want
to check out that review it'll be a bow
from duncan 3 303 and until then this is
van mkbhd
signing out peace